[Musique]
bonjour bertrand robe bonjour 10 me
bonjour à tout le monde et bonjour
barbara jean levy bonjour bertrand
caruge bonjour jimmy bonjour à tous les
auditeurs et toutes les auditrices de
martinique la première région alors on
vous présente comme ex journaliste
ancien journaliste mais en réalité on le
reste un toujours c'est comme le vélo
merde
donc donc voilà en tout cas voilà vous
êtes surtout auteur de livres alors
beaucoup de livres de jeunesse vous avez
écrit également des romans et puis là
vous venez de publier un nouvel ouvrage
intitulé martinique libre alors là là on
le montre un martinique libre un essai
politique oui alors au delà de partager
votre vision de la martinique ou sortir
quasiment puisque hier on a annoncé
qu'il y aurait une levée du couvre feu
etc c'est vrai combat oui on n'en sort
un peu vous ça vous soulage aussi vous
êtes contente oui deux ans avec avec ces
faits les gestes barrière je pense qu'il
faut continuer à les appliquer parce
qu'il ya un varier encore ok pas très
loin le béa 2 je crois donc qu'il faut
voilà il faut quand même être son
variant même on est souvent à rien
effectivement de micron donc il faut
être comme on dit en créole beati faut
faire attention on est soulagés puis
pour beaucoup de professionnels et pour
les familles ce sera vraiment un
soulagement pour ne pas faire peur on
annonce plus contagieux mais pas plus
dangereux que les variants qui l'ont
précédé donc voilà en tout cas cette
annonce est donc vous vous posez un
regard justement au sortir quasiment de
cette crise engendrée par la pandémie
coronavirus alors quel est votre
intention ou quel a été votre intention
et barbara jean eddy en écrivant ces
pages et puis en voulant les publier
c'est à dire que le plus grand nombre
puisse puisse lire ce que vous avez
écrit alors aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on
est on est on est dans l'air d'une
communication spontanée à cette année
tout le monde des médias en fait moi je
suis journaliste en journaliste mais
tout le monde et médias et c'est vrai
que le temps de l'écriture c'est un
temps de la réflexion et on avait vécu
comme beaucoup un autre nous de cette
crise on a été sidéré on s'adapte et je
pense que ça a démontré qu'on pouvait
s'adapter et faire face à des choses
extrêmement dure mais pour moi le fait
d'écrire c'était prendre un peu de recul
au cours d'une période qui était qui
était difficile mais en même temps ce
livre c'est une réflexion sur la
martinique depuis que je suis revenu
parce que j'ai quitté mon nid en 99 g
survenu en 2017 et depuis j'y vis avec
ma fille j'y travaille j'écris des
livres je rencontre des gens je
m'investis en politique eva je réfléchis
j'écris aussi des chroniques et j'ai
voulu donc voilà porter son regard avec
une perspective prendre ce temps là
voilà parce que le temps le temps de le
temps d'écriture il faut lire des choses
il faut réfléchir il faut les écrire les
relire et voilà prendre ce recul
pourquoi ce titre martinique libre
pourquoi parce que c'est presque une
forme de provocation
je trouve que le mot liberté auquel je
suis très attaché c'est un autre est
galvaudé et je pense qu'on est moins
libre qu'avant je pense qu'on se crée
des carcans son sommet des chaînes dans
dans la tête et on sait nous vend c'est
nous collectivement et individuellement
je pense qu'aussi qui a déjà dit il ya
des chaînes aussi qu'ils sont objectives
on parle beaucoup d'inégalités et de
pauvreté on parle de problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat les gens qui vivent du
rsa sont moins libre que ceux qui ne
vivent pas du rsa donc qu'il y a des il
ya des déchets l'objectif mais a aussi
des chaînes mentales des chaînes
psychologique des chaînes moral et des
chaînes collective et moi j'ai envie
j'ai envie de d'une martinique qui
s'émancipe et qui est sûr et qui assure
ses atouts et ses richesses parce que je
pense qu'on est un peuple une communauté
une collectivité extrêmement riche mais
peut-être encore plus riches pas établir
de différence entre les communautés mais
on a vraiment des atouts et des
richesses qui sont incomparables car
bien donc la quête de l'identité de la
liberté l'identité voilà là sont
toujours de mise pas la quête de
l'identité alors moi je suis par la
quête d'identité même si je pense que on
est on est trop facilement dans une
quête d'identité on est martiniquais il
faut assumer donc dans la voirie de se
chercher la condition mana il faut
arrêter se cherche et l'assomption de
l'identité martiniquaise
l'assomption de ceux qui de qui on est
devrait nous rendre plus libre moi je
dis je n'ai pas de problème avec mon
passé j'ai peut-être un problème avec
mon avenir allons régler l'avenir alors
l'ouvragé débute avec une série de
portraits et de tranches de vie
on va y venir le salon c'est vrai je les
laissais pour l'accueil le meilleur pour
la fin mais l'ouvragé débute c'est vrai
juste après le slam avec une série de
portraits deux tranches de vie de
quelques martiniquaise et martiniquais
aux profils différents âges différents
situations sociales différentes et voilà
et qui livre ces tranches de vie au sein
d'une société on y revient avec des
entraves mais où à la fois on le voit le
système d pour des brouillards en créole
est encore bien de mise finalement face
aux divers aléas c'est presque une
approche documentaire c'est vrai que l'
ouvrage marty clip c'est un objet un peu
plus riels il ya ce slam au début pour
et poésie urbaine après c'est un peu
c'est un peu finalement ma façon de
faire de la télévision or fait à l'écrit
est en fait ce sont des archétypes ce
sont ces personnes ce sont des gens que
je connais des gens que j'ai rencontrés
soit ce sont des gens qui sont des
individus ou ce sont des mélanges de
personnes que j'ai rencontrées au cours
de mes rencontres au cours de ma vie au
cours de mes activités professionnelles
ou d'ailleurs le chapitre s'intitule vie
martiniquaise tout à fait et en fait ça
vienne une observation qui ancien en
tout cas qui date d'au moins de 2010 est
la date de mon retour ici à me dire mais
comment je vis la martinique et mon
impression c'est que beaucoup de gens
vivent la martinique de façon compliqué
de façon difficile ce que j'appelle un
terme un peu marketing le disons le
comment dire le lusage en fait si vous
voulez l'expérience utilisateur voit
l'art marketing il parle d'une
expérience client d'expérience usagers
d'expérience utilisateur quel est mon
expérience d'utilisatrices de la partie
mon expérience de vécu martinique et
cette expérience là pour les mères de
famille pour les pour pousser pour des
femmes pour des sommes pour des gens qui
sont en difficulté d'emploi pour des
chefs d'entreprise pour des jeunes qui
sont étudiants des jeunes notamment qui
ont vécu le coc vie de cette expérience
est difficile et il s'agit pas juste de
dire ce à quoi une fois qu'on a dit ça
c'est voir les voies et peut-être qu'on
va en parler tout à l'heure et donc
c'était c'était ça relève du constat
donc c'est la première partie comme en
2022 qui sont ces martiniquais alors
j'ai pas fais une galerie de portraits
et oui ceci quelques exaucé car ce sont
des archétypes qui sont liées à mon
expérience et puis bon il y en a
quelques-uns qui qui me sont venues
aussi
avec la crise qu'on a connue en fin
d'année par exemple sept personnages et
de la cité ozanam c'est réel donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est c'est du
documentaire voilà documentaire alors à
travers ce livre on a l'impression que
vous faites le constat d'une société
martiniquaise en proie évidemment à
plusieurs défis une société
vieillissante qui à se confronter à des
défis de toutes sortes et dans les maux
chroniques se sont révélés avec encore
plus d'acuité certainement au cours de
la récente période un spécial que nous
avons vécu avec cette maladie à cauville
19 et que la plus encore eh bien nous
alors on y revient nous nous
collectivement avant un grand défi à
relever pour les générations à venir
vous êtes beaucoup fixé sur ses
obsessions 8 mai à trans est mon
obsession moi j'ai 54 ans j'en aurai 55
j'ai envie de dire j'ai passé la moitié
de ma vie j'ai déjà passé la moitié de
ma fille après si je m'engage
aujourd'hui si j'écris j'écris pour les
enfants si je continue à faire oeuvre de
journaliste c'est pour ma communauté
mais pour la presse et à dire que je dis
voilà on regarde dans le rétro regardons
aussi devant préparons ce à l'éducation
à l'information me paraissent des
thématiques essentielles je parle
beaucoup de pays empêcher c'est un terme
qui m'est venue la martinique est un
pays empêché parce que l'empêchement
c'est on peut faire mais on y compterait
un peu pas ya des choses qui nous qui
nous empêche de faire il faut libérer il
faut nous libérer de ses contres et là
tout à l'heure j'ai parlé effectivement
deux chaînes mentales il ya des chaînes
objective effectivement une situation
sociale économique de beaucoup d'entre
nous de trop nombreuses martiniquais est
trop beau trop dogmatique martin que je
pense que aujourd'hui effectivement pour
relever ces défis là il faut régler la
question de la gouvernance la à ces
jours ci on va commencer à parler de
statut je suis pas sûr que ça soit ça le
véritable problème pour moi le véritable
problème ce n'est pas le problème de du
contenant c'est le contenu qu'est-ce
qu'on donne effectivement qu'est ce
qu'on va mettre dans sa aujourd'hui si
on veut parler de gouvernance on nous
dit on veut plus de gens temps l'accord
j'entends effectivement le la guyane et
je suis sûr ça va arriver bientôt oui
voilà qu'est ce qu'on veut mais dans sa
aujourd'hui quand je parle de mon
expérience martiniquaise expériences
vécues ces mères de famille ou ccc aussi
c'est je pense à une amie c'est ses
salariés qui vont travailler qui
prennent le qui prennent le bus
attendent leur bus à tant d'abus ce
qu'est ce qui fait que cette problème ce
problème de mobilité globalement n'est
pas aisément au passage vous ne menez
vous ne ménagez pas le monde politique
un aussi justement alors les maîtres
peut-être pas toutes et tous à tout le
monde n'est pas à mettre dans le même
sac enfin voila on ressent par moments
que vous auriez voulu qu'ils s'engagent
plus de justement dans cette action de
restauration de confiance alors de deux
sursauts lucide que nous devons avoir la
la croisée des chemins non oui enfin je
ne sais pas si je n'ai ménage pas je
viens y prennent leur part atteignant
comme non c'est pas que je les aiderai
tilt je suis tout à fait comme indien je
suis rempli de gratitude à l'égard des
c'est pas facile d'être politique ou
femme politique c'est un engagement
c'est un sacerdoce d'effacer c'est
difficile ce sont des sacrifices aussi
mais je dis qu'il faut être j'ai envie
d'être plus sincères moi je pense qu'il
manque un peu de sincérité dans cet
engagement parce qu'il ya des questions
électoralistes voilà aujourd'hui on va
rentrer dans une période si les idées
présidentielle après jce l'atvs
d'ailleurs ce que vous appelez la
participation gestion louis géant
démocrate je suis républicaine je suis
démocrate la jonction la question peut
être aussi il faut prendre ça on peut
pas dire moi je ne suis pas satisfaite
quand j'entends les gens dire ouais ils
sont tous pourris j'entends ça des fois
dans les coups de gueule way tout pareil
ou pas car la chaîne non à les lire les
programmes ya des différences entre eux
par exemple la présidentielle entre eux
manama tout madame hidalgo monsieur
macro monsieur mélenchon mais ce sont 12
à la norme et non mais c'est un pas en
temps mais un train arrivait des images
un temps donné comme on est en temps de
vous saviez de jazz parole mais
n'appelle pas à voter pour celle des
personnes que j'ai jamais dis pas je ne
dis pas je ne dis pas pot-pourri
j'appelle à voter je n'appelle pas à
voter là en tout cas je dis qu'il faut
faire la différence on peut pas mettre
tout le monde dans le même panier il y a
déjà des pourparlers des présidentielles
il ya des thématiques à des enjeux à
cette élection présidentielle qui sont
au-delà de notre petit comment dire de
nos préoccupations quotidiennes ce sont
des enjeux de janvier aux pressions de
société ok on va vers la nation est
notre direction ce que je veux dire pour
revenir en fait à votre question je
parlais de gouvernance je n'ai gratte in
pas spécialement les on peut dire qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent face à leurs
responsabilités avec sincérité ce ne
sont pas que des questions électorales
avant les élections je fais ça tu fais
ça c'est des questions d'engagement sur
la résolution
il nous faut nous interrompre pour le
flash d'information et puis nous
reprenons donc l'entretien juste après
l'interview agrémenté donc des appels
des auditrices et des auditeurs
certainement travailler